Speaker 1: All right. Let's talk about the
Dilbert Scott Adams fiasco. So some of you
may recall that Scott Adams, the guy who draws the
Dilbert cartoon, has been on this program before.
And we used to kind of mix it up on Twitter.
And then a few years ago, I think it was kind
of early in the pandemic, he just blocked me
on Twitter. And I know that I could, like,
log out to see what he's posting, but I don't care
that much. So I've not been following Scott Adams
since he cut me off. And when he would be on,
we would have like spirited discussions, which I
thought were generally pretty good. But something
kind of started to go wrong with Scott Adams. And
when he banned me, a black ban me when he blocked
me from Twitter, he really seemed to almost like
crack like it was I don't remember what it was
over, but I think I said, Oh, I think that you're
arguing in bad faith about something. And he
went crazy, insulted me and then blocked me and
just seems to have kind of descended into a dark
place over the last several years. I found out
over the weekend that he unleashed a completely
racist meltdown style tirade on Twitter and that
this subsequently led to a bunch of newspapers
saying, yeah, we're going to get rid of Dilbert,
We're all set with Dilbert. We're not going
to have it anymore. Now, I admit, personally,
it really bums me out. I used to love Dilbert
growing up, and I know a lot of people like, Oh,
Dilbert, so lame. It's boring. Whatever. I really
liked it growing up, and it was just kind of a
sad thing to see Scott Adams descend into such
political insanity. And now, even beyond that,
we're I don't know this this seems to be going
beyond the political to the personal. Something
really seems to be going on. But fear not, he
has some defenders. Elon Musk has come out of
the woodwork to defend Scott Adams. So let's
look at what's going on. CNN article from this
morning says Elon Musk defended Dilbert creator
Scott Adams after hundreds of newspapers stopped
printing the comic strip because of Adams recent
racist comments. Last week, Adams called black
Americans a hate group and suggested white people
should, quote, get the hell away from them. Oof!
Adams effectively encouraged segregation. In a
shocking rant on his YouTube channel, his comments
came in response to a poll from the conservative
firm Rasmussen Reports. Not a good pollster,
by the way, that said 53% of black Americans
agree with the statement It's okay to be white.
In response to a tweet, Twitter owner Musk
said Sunday that, quote, The media is racist.
You know, it's so funny. The right loves to say
you got to be really careful when you call someone
racist. That's one of the most serious things you
can do. How can you call Scott Adams racist when
you don't know what's in his head? And regardless
of what he said, he might not really be racist
and all these things. Oh, Elon Musk is defending
him. The media is racist. Yep. Checks out. No,
no critique needed there. Musk also didn't
criticize Scott Adams comments, and Musk said
without evidence that, quote, For a very long
time the US media was racist against nonwhite
people. Now they're racist against whites and
Asians. Same thing happened with elite colleges
and high schools in America. Maybe they can try
not being racist. Musk later agreed with a tweet
saying Adams comments weren't good but had an
element of truth. He accused the media of giving
black victims of police violence disproportionate
coverage over white victims of police violence.
Black people are more likely to die from
police use of force than white people,
according to multiple studies. What were
Adams comments? Well, here they are,
he said on his YouTube show, quote, If nearly
half of all blacks are not okay with white people,
according to this poll, not according to me.
That's a hate group. I don't want to have
anything to do with them. And I would say based
on the current way things are going, the best
advice I would give to white people is to get the
hell away from black people. Just get the eff away
because there's no fixing this. He has since said
on Twitter he was only advising people to avoid
hate. So anyway, we now have all these articles
about how newspapers are dropping the comic strip.
And of course, all of these right wingers are
saying this is now censorship. Some newspapers
said it's not a difficult decision. The Cleveland
Plain Dealer said We are dropping the Dilbert
comic strip because of Scott Adams racist rant.
USA Today's network also dropped it. So listen,
it's all the exact same stuff that we always
hear and it's the same routine. Scott Adams,
in response to this, tweeted, quote, Dilbert
has been canceled from all newspapers, websites,
calendars and books because I gave some
advice. Everyone agreed with me. Wow. My
syndication partner canceled me. So listen, I
think something is very wrong. I think Scott
Adams is struggling personally, but that doesn't
mean we excuse the things he said. Everybody here
is exercising their rights. Scott Adams expressed
his speech in this insane time. Tirade on YouTube,
which he followed up on Twitter. The people who
read it responded and said, I either like that or
I don't. And some of them stopped following Scott
Adams, and some of them said, I'm not going to
read the Dilbert strip anymore. And some of them
wrote to newspapers and said, Don't carry this
anymore. Everybody is speaking. This is speech.
And then newspapers made a decision with whatever
barometer they want to use to make that decision.
Some said we're no longer going to carry the comic
strip. Everybody is expressing their rights.
It's the free market at work. It's action and
reaction. Remember, we're not talking about the
First Amendment because this is not about the
government doing anything. But we are talking here
about everybody's rights to say what they want.
And sometimes things you say have consequences. A
lot of people struggle or are unwilling to accept
that, quote, free speech sometimes
used colloquially, doesn't mean my
speech can't have consequences or therefore
it is no longer free speech. And of course,
good thing Elon Musk showed up and cleared it
up by reminding us that the media is racist,
which really added significant moral clarity,
as you can imagine. So let's. Everybody here
has been allowed to say whatever they want.
You don't have a right to have a syndicated
comic strip. If Scott Adams wants to take control
back, he can keep drawing Dilbert and just release
it on his website. He would then control the
platform. Nobody would be able to, quote,
cancel him. And that's absolutely something that
he can do. But it's seeming like a sort of sad
I don't want to call it the end for Scott Adams,
but it's been a very sad decline, particularly for
me, because I really used to like the comic strip
when I was 12 years old. I thought it was good.